ça leur donne ça va non non je crois que
j'ai une cystite attend une fille tu
t'es sûr de ton couleurs oui car je
trouve ça me brûle ah oui donc ça c'est
une bronchite
1 parce que les suicides c'est quand tu
fais pipi caca c'est justement quand je
touche je fais un peu pipi aussi non oui
maintenant n'ont rien à voir dans ce
système
[Musique]
est-ce que vous avez déjà uriner des
lames de rasoir alors au sens littéral
ya peu de chance dans la mesure où pour
ça il faudrait boire des lames de rasoir
et que pour qu'elle arrive telle quelle
jusqu'à la vessie faudrait d'abord
qu'elle passe par les reins etc
en revanche si vous avez déjà fait une
cystite il est fort probable que vous
voyez très bien de quoi je suis en train
de parler
il est même fort probable que vous soyez
en train de serrer les jambes en
grimaçant rien qu'en y repensant l'autre
problème de la cystite en plus des lames
de rasoir dans l'urètre c'est que ça
arrive comme ça un petit peu sans
prévenir
mais heureusement il ya des trucs à
faire avant pour éviter que ça arrive
cependant pour que ça s'arrête le plus
vite possible et après pour pas que ça
recommence
mais bon avant de voir tout ça partant
du principe qu'il faut connaître son
ennemi pour bien combattre on va un peu
se pencher sur cette femme c'est la
cystite c'est une infection urinaire au
niveau de la vessie d'ailleurs si sts ça
veut dire merci et it ça veut dire
inflammation oui parce que la douleur
c'est le résultat de l'inflammation qui
est déclenchée par l'organisme pour
lutter contre l'infection ça gonfle ça
chauffe à pique ça brûle
salah de la sensation d'avoir un poids
sur la vessie jusqu'au douleur mais
j'aurais bien bien au moment des
mictions c'est à dire quand on urine
en plus de ça les urines ou peuvent
devenir troubles changer de couleur
sentir mauvais voire contenir du sang et
vous pouvez avoir envie de faire pipi
très souvent sans forcément y arriver ou
alors al'inverse pas pouvoir vous
retenir voilà une cystite ça peut
ressembler à ça par contre attention si
vous avez mal dans le bas du dos ou que
vous avez de la fièvre
là c'est pas une cystite c'est une
infection au niveau des reins
pyélonéphrite et là c'est du sérieux il
faut filer chez le médecin bon mais
alors pourquoi on chope des infections
urinaires comme ça sans prévenir c'est
quoi ces sales bêtes
d'où elles viennent à rouen et rentrent
pas dans l'immense majorité des cas ces
sales bêtes c'est des escherichia coli
c'est à dire des bactéries de notre
flore intestinale du coup ça répond un
peu à la question d'où elles viennent
elles viennent exactement de là où vous
fumer et comme c'est juste à côté elle
rentre par le méat urinaire
c'est à dire de l'orifice de l'urètre le
trou du cul ensuite elle remonte jusqu'à
la vessie et avec leurs petits crochets
s accroche dedans bon c'est vrai rigolez
pas c'est vraiment comme ça que ça se
passe
et donc je pense qu'une bonne moitié
d'entre vous au moins est déjà au
courant mais je leur dis quand même ça
touche presque exclusivement les
personnes qui ne sont pas équipés de
pénis or hier les femmes
pour simplifier pour vulgariser alors
vous allez me dire genre avoir un pénis
vaccine contre les escherichia coli
alors non pas vraiment mais un peu quand
même
en fait c'est une histoire dure être
l'urètre masculin il est 5 à 10 fois
plus long que l'urètre féminin et ce à
deux conséquences
d'abord ça n'est plus de chemin pour
arriver jusqu'à la vessie et ensuite
l'entrée elle est plus loin de la nuit
là normalement ça dépend comment c'est
en gp a priori ici donc voilà on estime
qu'une femme sur deux a au moins une
cystite au cours de sa vie surtout après
ses premiers rapports sexuels et après
la ménopause
mais attention pas seulement ça peut
arriver tout au long de la vie et ça
peut toucher tout le monde et donc comme
ça prévient pas toujours une fois que
c'est là qu'est ce qu'on fait première
option les traitements sans ordonnance
vous pouvez allez chez votre pharmacien
lui expliquer ce qui se passe et lui
demander conseil
les personnes qui ont déjà eu à se
débattre avec une cystite ont forcément
entendu parler du cranberries ou
canneberge enfoncé ses conseillers un
peu partout mais pour être précis ça n'a
pas fait la preuve scientifique de son
efficacité
c'est pas moi qui ai dit c est la nièce
et en gros c'est pareil aussi pour tous
les remèdes de grand-mère genre l'eau
citronnée les infusions teint ou les
cataplasmes of war ou le pharmacien peut
aussi vous proposer un traitement à base
de des mano c'est une forme de glucose
qui a la propriété d'empêcher les
escherichia coli de s'accrocher à la
paroisse de la vessie ou de décrocher
celles qui sont déjà là du coup les
escherichia coli sont évacués dans les
urines d'où l'intérêt de boire beaucoup
l'autre option c'est d'aller chez le
médecin soit d'emblée soit au bout de
quelques jours parce que ça passe pas et
surtout si vous avez mal dans le bas du
dos et de la fièvre comme on l'a dit et
si vous allez le voir il vous donnera
sûrement le traitement le
courant des antibiotiques adaptés à la
bactérie en cause
il vous fera sans doute faire piquer sur
une petite bandelette qui changent de
couleur si vous avez une infection
et si c'est le cas vim quand tu me dis
attention on est d'accord que le seul
moyen de savoir s'il faut prendre des
antibiotiques
c'est d'aller chez le médecin je vous
refais pas le topo mais vous vous
souvenez prendre des antibiotiques qui
traînent chez vous c'est le meilleur
moyen d'aggraver la résistance des
bactéries aux médicaments et ça c'est
une mauvaise idée
je vous mets le lien vers mes vidéos sur
l'antibiorésistance là juste en dessous
vous retournerez jeter un petit coup
d'oeil
retenez juste ces deux règles d'or quand
on a fini un traitement aux
antibiotiques
on ramène ce qui reste à la pharmacie et
on en reprend que si le médecin a
prescrit à nouveau en plus des
différents traitements il ya des choses
que vous pouvez faire de votre côté déjà
mais peut-être pas envie parce que faire
pipi s'applique mais buvez beaucoup
d'eau pour bien refait la bêtise
[Musique]
libéraux l'ont ensuite pour limiter les
brûlures
n'hésitez pas à prendre de façon
systématique des médicaments contre la
douleur
classiques ou des antispasmodiques là
encore il y en a sans ordonnance demandé
lesquels sont les plus efficaces
mais comme d'habitude le nerf de la
guerre c'est la prévention
et comme les cystites ont une fâcheuse
tendance à récidiver le mieux c'est de
faire en sorte de ne pas en avoir ne
serait ce que pour pas avoir
l'impression qu'on urines des p'tits
clous rouillés qui sortent du four
d'abord avec des traitements préventifs
donc clairement pas les antibiotiques
pour les raisons dont on a parlé mais
les probiotiques par exemple qui aident
à reconstituer la flore vaginale qui est
chargé de botter les fesses des
escherichia coli comtesse points et le
dé mannose dont on vient de parler qui
aident à les décrocher et à les évacuer
si elle arrive quand même à entrer dans
la vie mais c'est pas tout il ya aussi
tout un tas d'habitude à prendre ou à
perdre pour mettre toutes les chances de
son côté
donc voilà sept conseils
éviter les pics d'abord les petits
conseils d'hygiène de base qui vont sans
dire mais qui vont quand même mieux en
le disant
la toile est déjà la petite toilette
comme on dit dans le jargon
si on se lasse pas assez ça favorise la
prolifération des germes
mais gardez à l'esprit que le mieux est
l'ennemi du bien
lavez votre petit matériel une fois par
jour pas moins mais pas plus
avec un savon doux classique oublier
tout ce qui est savon antiseptique
lingettes déodorants intimes douches
vaginales ou je sais pas quoi ça
déséquilibre votre flore et du cou en
gros les vigiles laisse rentrer
n'importe qui quand vous allez aux
toilettes
quelle que soit l'activité pratiquée
essuyez-vous de l'avant vers l'arrière
d'un seul geste
les parents des va et vient l'histoire
ne pas amener les escherichia coli qui
sont en coulisses sur le devant de la
scène
buvez minimum un litre et demi par jour
pour uriner au moins un litre et demi
par jour ça stagne moins dans la ville
suisse à reims si vous voulez et ça
évacue les germes qui font trempette et
surtout mais on en a déjà parlé dans une
autre vidéo ne vous retenez pas si vous
avez envie et n'arrêtait pas tant que
vous n'avez pas tous fini même si ça
pique fait pipi
après les rapports sexuels pardon d'être
un peu triviale mais ça permet de purger
le tuyau et d'évacuer d'un coup de
karcher les petites bêtes qui serait en
train de faire de la varappe
le lingot trimestre alors deux petites
précisions d'abord vous n'êtes pas
obligé de faire pipi
immédiatement après je vais vous pouvez
attendre d'être au toilette paris est
aussi un rapport sexuel ça n'implique
pas forcément une pénétration plein
d'autres moyens d'amener des germes dans
cette zone
pour ses 10 pour rester dans le thème il
semble que les spermicides favorise les
cystites donc si vous avez possibilité
de choisir un autre moyen de
contraception
c'est mieux dans un autre registre on a
constaté sans vraiment comprendre
pourquoi que les cystites arrivait plus
souvent quand on est est constipé
donc dans le doute mangez des fruits des
légumes verts des fibres bougez-vous le
plus possible et buvez plein d'eau mais
c'est en automne évitez les vêtements et
les sous vêtements trop serrés
ça favorise la promiscuité alors la
promiscuité ça veut pas dire que la
mariée c'est une simple trop bien
en honneur c'est à dire que deux trucs
se retrouve un peu plus proche qui
devraient en l'occurrence l'anus et
lurette qu'ils sont comprimées l'un
contre l'autre
un peu comme dans le métro pour celles
et ceux qui connaissent et préférez les
sous-vêtements en coton voit la dtcc
fini pour aujourd'hui on se retrouve
très vite pour de nouvelles vidéos
d'ici là prenez soin de vous et prenez
soin des autres
mettez vous bien et surtout portez vous
bien
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]